[Musique]
pour certains la surprise de l'élection
présidentielle ça sera la victoire de la
droite républicaine
pour nous ce sera la logique car seule
la droite républicaine est capable de
redresser la france est de rassembler
les français nous sommes les seuls à
proposer une alternative crédible à
monsieur macro nous sommes les seuls à
former une équipe pour gouverner la
france je veux nous faire gagner en 2022
ministre de jacques chirac de nicolas
sarkozy avec leur confiance
j'ai su mener des réformes difficiles et
j'ai eu aussi l'honneur de diriger notre
famille politique ensemble nous avons
remporté des victoires sur des
territoires réputé paraît-il imprenable
comme vous je veux tourner la page du
quinquennat macro je veux être le
président qui rétablira l'autorité de
l'état je veux être le président qui
mettra fin au centralisme bureaucratique
parisien je veux être le président d'une
société du travail dans laquelle le
travail paye à nouveau je projette je
les construis en allant à votre
rencontre en vous écoutant je serai un
président pour les français
les amis ensemble nous allons renouer
avec les grandes pages de notre histoire
la france fière fière d'elle même et de
son histoire la france respecte et qui
parle au monde la france forte et
courageuse la france rassembler ensemble
faisons gagner la droite pour la france
et les français
chaque lavier qui a la parole
merci
merci à nîmes merci aurélien merci à
christian d'avoir permis les conditions
de ce congrès du rassemblement le 4
décembre prochain et merci aussi à vous
toutes et vous tous quels que soient vos
choix et vos préférences au moment où
vous rentrez dans cette salle merci nous
permettre de faire vivre cette
démocratie
permettez moi aussi de vous dire que ce
choix du congrès
c'est le choix du rassemblement mais
c'est un bien meilleur choix que si nous
avions fait le choix d'une primaire
parce que dans un congrès on sait qu'ils
votent dans un congrès il n'ya pas
d'arbitré qui viennent juste un jour
alors qu'ils n'ont jamais envie de voter
pour la droite et le centre faire leur
choix et faire leurs courses ici on vote
en famille est ici on est dans une
famille voilà pourquoi j'ai fait le
choix de ce congrès parce que c'est le
choix gagnant parce que c'est le choix
du rassemblement
et vous l'avez vu personne ne se trompe
l'ambiance n'a rien à voir avec ce que
nous avons pu connaître les fois
précédentes
oui nous nous respectons bien sûr qu'il
ya des différences bien sûr qu'il ya les
mêmes ambitions mais aussi l'intérêt
général du pays il ya aussi le sens de
l'état qui fait que dans les débats
télévisés n'en déplaise à certains c'est
pas la foire d'empoigné et non
nous avons des propositions qui peuvent
être différentes mais nous savons au
final que nous aurons une obligation
celle d'être unis et de faire campagne
ensemble je le dis à valérie pécresse à
michel barnier à philippe juvin eric
ciotti si les adhérents me désigne le 4
décembre je veux faire campagne avec
vous et si le 24 avril les français nous
font confiance je veux gouverner le pays
et je veux redresser le pays avec chacun
d'entre vous et aussi avec tous les
talents de notre famille politique les
talents sur lesquels on sait s'appuyer
dès aujourd'hui et je voudrais rendre
hommage au remarquable travail qui est
fait à l'assemblée nationale par damien
abad et l'ensemble des députés par
françois-xavier bellamy et les députés
européens
et aussi par bruno retailleau sénat et
vous permettrait souhaiter un bon
anniversaire à bruno retailleau
aujourd'hui
alors pourquoi cette tonalité dans les
débats tout simplement parce que nous ne
sommes pas des adversaires et en ce qui
me concerne et vous l'avez vu à chaque
fois je n'ai qu'un seul adversaire dans
cette élection présidentielle c'est
monsieur macron parce que comme vous je
veux tourner la page de monsieur
maquereau à la tête de l'état
alors je sais bien et je le vois en
disant bonjour en serrant la main
certains sont réservés à mon égard ce
serait bien la seule fois aujourd'hui ce
ne serait pas le cas de la part de
certains et oui parce que bertrand il
est parti oui à un moment donné j'ai
fait ce choix choix qui n'était pas si
simple que cela pour moi qui ai rejoint
le rpr à l'époque j'avais 16-17 ans et
je me suis engagé pour jacques chirac
son charisme son énergie et je suis
intimement convaincu que s'il avait été
au second tour face à françois
mitterrand le sort aurait été différent
et notre perry n'aurait pas été aussi
malmené pendant les septennats de
monsieur mitterrand j'ai exercé les
fonctions chez les jeunes et les moins
jeunes chez les toujours jeunes encore
jusqu'à avoir cette responsabilité cet
honneur que m'a confiée nicolas sarkozy
en me demandant de présider notre
famille politique secrétaire général des
militants vous souvenez c'est comme cela
que vous m'appeliez c'est aussi comme ça
que certains dans les cénacles parisiens
m'appelait s'était pas toujours une
qualité dans leur bouche mais à partir
du moment où c'est est ce que vous
pensiez moi ça m'allait très bien parce
que je suis comme vous j'ai gravi les
différents échelons et j'ai toujours été
bien avec vous comme je le suis
aujourd'hui coeur de ma région avec les
habitants de la région et comme je suis
avec vous tous les milliers tous les
soirs quand nous faisons ces réunions
ensemble alors c'est vrai qu'en 2017
j'ai fait un choix différent parce que
je n'ai pas accepté c'était un choix de
conviction je sais que certains dans
cette salle n'ont pas voté comme moi au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle c'est
votre droit mais je vais vous expliquer
mon choix je suis dans l'une des régions
les plus difficiles pour un homme de
droite c'est vrai et j'ai toujours eu à
combattre les extrêmes l'extrême gauche
et l'extrême droite dans ma région avant
la france insoumise on parlait du
mouvement pour un parti des travailleurs
lutte ouvrière et je sais la façon dont
à chaque fois les extrêmes exploite la
colère et la misère des gens jamais pour
régler leurs problèmes uniquement pour
exploiter leurs problèmes j'ai toujours
combattu comme à l'époque jacques chirac
nicolas sarkozy philippe séguin ont
imposé également à nos candidats de ne
pas mêler leurs voix à l'extrême droite
au moment des élections régionales
c'était en 98 je les ai toujours
combattu et il est vrai que le fait que
nous ne voulions pas prendre de position
commune pour faire barrage à madame le
pen je n'ai pas accepté alors j'ai fait
ce choix j'ai fait ce choix et je le dis
aussi clairement je n'ai pas rejoint un
autre parti politique alors que la
proposition m'a été faite et même mon
association la manufacture je n'ai
jamais voulu en faire un parti politique
pour ne pas faire concurrence
aux à faire concurrence aux républicains
au sein de la région des hauts de france
la majorité de ma majorité ce sont les
républicains au sein de la région des
hautes france mais vice-président la
plupart sont effectivement les
républicains alors vous le voyez je n'ai
eu qu'un parti politique le rpr l'ump
les républicains je n'ai qu'une famille
politique mais surtout regardez moi bien
moi je n'ai jamais trahi en rejoignant
les rives de la macro ni je sais qui je
suis et je sais où j'habite
si je m'engage avec toute mon énergie si
je m'engage de toutes mes forces dans
cette élection c'est parce que j'ai
conscience qu'au-delà de notre ambition
à chacun ce qui se joue c'est tout
simplement la survie ou la disparition
de notre famille politique et ça vous le
sentez bien vous le sentez bien parce
que vous savez qu'à parti comme le nôtre
héritier du général de gaulle de georges
pompidou de jacques chirac de nicolas
sarkozy
cette famille politique non seulement ne
peut pas disparaître mais ne peut pas
être une formation politique de deuxième
plan de deuxième division jamais je n'ai
envie que nous ne ressemblions au parti
socialiste à cette gauche qui pour une
partie à oublier l'idéal républicain
pour se vautrer dans l'islamo gauchisme
ce parti socialiste est capable
d'investir sa candidate à plus de 70%
des voix mais dont on voit bien qu'elles
ne dépassent pas 5 % et dont on se
demande à quel moment elle va être
obligé de s'effacer derrière le candidat
écologiste ans moyennant des
circonscriptions ça n'est pas cela notre
vocation ça n'est pas cela notre destin
mais n'oublions pas non plus que nous ne
sommes pas seuls dans le paysage
politique dans le paysage politique
français aujourd'hui il n'y a qu' il y
en a qui n'attendent que cela notre
disparition que cela notre effacement je
parle bien évidemment des vautours les
vautours ce sont les extrêmes madame le
pen en tête qui n'attend qu'une chose
c'est que nous soyons éliminé du second
tour pour que nos électeurs temps ils
ont envie de tourner la page macron se
tournent vers elle pour les
présidentielles et pour les législatives
et de l'autre côté vous avez le
fossoyeur le fossoyeur de la vie
politique française qui est monsieur
macron ce fossoyeur qu'ils n'essayent
qu'une chose de draguer déjà un certain
nombre d'élus pour ensuite récupérer un
certain nombre d'électeurs alors je vous
le dis entre le fossoyeur et les
vautours on va se tenir droit la tête
haute et on va se battre pour la france
et pour les français
certains de vos amis vous diront même
que vous soyez là ou pas là qu'est ce
que ça change dans la vie politique et
si la france et ce pays qui aime tant la
politique nous sommes le peuple qui aime
le plus la politique et on a besoin de
partis politiques vous savez quoi
enraciné porteur de valeurs oui de
valeur pas qu'ils soutiennent un
gouvernement ou qui profitent de la
misère ou de la colère on le voit bien
en marche n'existe déjà plus même pas
cinq ans après sa naissance pourquoi
parce qu'il ne symbolise aucune valeur
et aucun au raffinement et que dire des
extrêmes qui ne sont pas des partis
politiques en ce sens qu'il n'ya pas
d'idéal de projet de progrès et l'espoir
en ce qui nous concerne si nous nous
disparaissions mes amis qui incarnera
l'indépendance et la grandeur de la
france personne qui parlera d'autorité
travail personne qui aura toujours envie
de rassembler les français comme nos
pères fondateurs nous l'enseigné
personnes c'est la raison pour laquelle
cette élection présidentielle c'est
aussi l'enjeu de l'avenir de la famille
politique et de notre pays
alors dans cette campagne je vous le dis
oui je vous le dis ce ne sont pas les
sondages qui désigneront le candidat du
congrès non ce ne sont pas les sondages
vous allez juger en fonction de
différents critères moi j'ai la
conviction que ce sera aussi une
question d'énergie d'énergie pour aller
gagner cette élection la question n'est
pas seulement gagné le congrès
la question sera ensuite de se hisser
dans un deuxième tour en rejetant les
extrêmes et ensuite au deuxième tour de
pouvoir battre monsieur macron temps
vous sentez bien autour de vous que ce
sont les solutions de la droite dont les
français dont vos amis vous dise voilà
ce qu'il faut pour le pays oui la droite
la droite républicaine celle qui a des
valeurs et cette énergie la halle sera
fondamental pour aller gagner cette
élection présidentielle et il y aura
ensuite le projet et il y aura ensuite
le projet ne faisons pas campagne pour
nous mêmes nous faisons campagne pour ce
que nous avons de plus cher notre pays
notre patrie et nos enfants nos
petits-enfants c'est en cela que le
projet que je porte c'est en ça le
projet que je veux que nous portons
ensemble dès le 4 décembre soit un
projet de redressement de réconciliation
et d'espoir j'ai bien dit espoir parce
que c'est de cela dans notre famille
politique est aujourd'hui porteuse elle
apporte des solutions mais elles amènent
espoir que vivent nos concitoyens ils
veulent vivre en paix et en sécurité
ils veulent vivre dignement de leur
travail ils veulent que leurs enfants
connaissent un avenir meilleur qu'eux
mêmes et ils veulent continuer à être
dans un grand pays respecté et qui
continue à étonner le monde comme le
disait jacques chirac tout à l'heure
encore voilà ce qu'ils veulent et le
projet que je vous propose il n'est pas
autour de 30 priorité il y aura pas 110
propositions 300 propositions non il y
aura trois priorités
l'autorité les territoires et le travail
ce que je veux comme préalable à tout
c'est que nous mettions fin au désordre
que connaît notre pays et nous ne
mettrons fin à ce désordre que par le
respect de l'autorité et par le retour
de la sécurité c'est l'impunité zéro qui
doit s'appliquer à tout moment et sur
tout le territoire français
l'app unités 0 le retour de l'ordre le
retour de la sécurité c'est partout en
métropole dans le coeur de certains
quartiers en ruralité sans oublier
l'outre-mer où nous voyons aujourd'hui
ce qui se passe en guadeloupe nous avons
le droit à la sécurité je veux
l'autorité la sécurité partout
mais si vous voulez mettre un terme à
l'impunité commençons par protéger ce
qui nous protège nos policiers nationaux
municipaux nos gendarmes bien évidemment
ce qui symbolise l'autorité les pompiers
les maires mais parlons des policiers
pour commencer aujourd'hui ils sont
devenus des cibles comment voulez vous
protéger la république qu'en ce qui nous
protège sont aujourd'hui temps mis en
cause c'est bien évidemment une
intervention sur le terrain qui peut
dégénérer et pour eux c'est leur vie qui
peut être mise en danger ça n'est pas un
métier comme les autres et puis surtout
quand ils interviennent ils peuvent se
fait remettre en cause parce qu'ils
arrêtent les délinquants eux mêmes et
pour cela ils doivent se sentir
également soutenu entendons nous bien
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre savent
bien ils ont à coeur de respecter la loi
républicaine celui ou celle qui s'en
éloignent doit être sanctionné mais je
vous le dis
ne comptez pas sur moi en tant que
président de la république pour un jour
arborer un t-shirt dénonçant les
violences policières comme monsieur
maquereau a osé le faire à angoulême
jamais jamais si on protège ce qui nous
protège on est du côté les forces de
l'ordre et pour cela si l'on veut que
l'on arrête de se servir d'eux comme des
cibles un jour à coups de tirs de
mortier ou un jour comme à la duchère en
leur tirant dessus pour les tuer je
souhaite que l'on mette en place dans
notre pays des peines minimum
obligatoire celui qui agressera
physiquement un policier à l'issue d'un
procès ça sera une peine minimum d'un an
de prison ferme voilà ce que je propose
pour que la peur change de camp
je veux être précis sur ce sujet
certains peuvent se dire 'je aviez vu
remettre en place les peines plancher je
veux aller au delà des peines planchers
nicolas sarkozy rachida dati a eu le
courage de porter ces peines qui avaient
une véritable efficacité mais force est
de reconnaître qu au fur et à mesure
nombre de magistrats non plus appliqué
ces peines plancher parce qu'ils
pouvaient s'en exonérer je souhaite
qu'il y ait un changement de la
constitution et à l'automne je vous
demanderais de vous prononcer après que
les parlementaires les faits je vous
demanderais ne vous prêt prononcé comme
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens pour
modifier la constitution et la loi
pénale pour la récidive et dans des cas
comme ceux d' atteinte aux forces de
l'ordre il y ait un maximum mais qu'il y
ait aussi un minimum les magistrats
pourront continuer à individualiser les
peines mais sans descendre en dessous de
ce minimum nous n'aurons plus ce que
nous avons connu avec les peines
plancher c'est à dire une impunité
possible la fin de l'impunité c'est
aussi la garantie de la sanction voilà
ce que je veux et je vous garantie une
chose rien n'est simple rien ne sera
simple et je vous garantis que quand on
attaque un commissariat comme à
champigny quand il y a
un commerce qui doit fermer ses portes à
17h encore une fois à lyon parce que la
sécurité ne peut plus être assuré quand
il y aura un rodéo urbain et bien je
devrais conseil amont ministre de
l'intérieur pour qu'il y ait une riposte
la riposte de l'état la riposte
républicaine rien de pire pour ces
voyous de voir que le lendemain de leurs
exactions rien ne se passe parce que les
consignes ne sont pas donnés aux forces
de l'ordre si vous voulez que l'impunité
cesse il faut qu'il y à une riposte
républicaine avec des forces de l'ordre
avec des interrogatoires avec des
saisies s'il ya lieu avec des
interpellations et surtout quand il y a
lieu de véritable condamnation pensons à
ces braves gens qui sont dans ces
quartiers pensons à ces braves gens qui
sont devenus des otages dont je n'ai pas
envie un jour qu'ils aient envie de se
défendre par eux mêmes c'est à la
république et c'est à l'état de défendre
comme nous devons bien sûr nous protéger
les uns et les autres
c'est reprendre en main notre politique
comme nous devons reprendre en main
notre politique migratoire mais je veux
au préalable je veux au préalable posé
des principes ces principes sont les
suivants ce n'est pas à la france de
s'adapter aux besoins de l'immigration 7
à l'immigration de s'adapter aux besoins
de la france je veux également vous dire
que je ne confondrait jamais
l'immigration illégale que je veux
combattre avec l'immigration légale que
je veux contrôler et diminuer faisons
bien la part des choses refusons les
amalgames mais nous savons bien que nous
avons besoin aujourd'hui de reprendre
les choses en main parce que je n'ai pas
envie non plus que notre pays nos
concitoyens aient le sentiment que tout
a basculé que plus rien n'est sous
contrôle je n'ai pas envie que ce soit
la xénophobie ou le fait de considérer
que tout étranger soit un danger qui
viennent justement s'installer dans nos
esprits dans nos têtes je ne veux pas
cela parce qu'ici c'est la droite
républicaine et la droite républicaine
elle s'est clairement quel est son
chemin la droite républicaine elle a
rien à voir avec les laxistes ils sont
au pouvoir depuis 2012 elle n'a rien à
voir avec les extrémistes ce que je vous
propose c'est que nous mettions
notamment place en france un système de
quotas migratoires où chaque année les
parlementaires décideront qui rentrent
sur le territoire et à quel titre
l'immigration du travail sera réduite
l'immigration des étudiants même si on
me fait ce reproche sera diminuée divisé
par deux et l'immigration familiale sera
divisé par trois quand on vient en
france on doit s'assurer que celles et
ceux qui viennent par le français vous
ne pouvez pas vous intégrez quand vous
ne parlez pas la langue du pays dans
lequel vous l'avenir et puis surtout
et puis surtout ce que je souhaite c'est
que celles et ceux qui viennent
bénéficie d'un passeport républicain pas
de casier judiciaire et l'autre par
adhérer aux principes de la république
et ses principes ils sont très simples
aucune loi religieuse les égales ou
supérieures aux lois de la république et
la femme est l'égal de l'homme voilà les
principes qu'il faut respecter
mais je veux aller vite je ne veux pas
attendre quelques mois ou quelques
années je veux que nous puissions
décider très rapidement et avant l'été
je demanderai à mon ministre de
l'intérieur de prendre une circulaire
qui abrogera la circulaire de 2012 parce
que cette circulaire de 2012 dit que
même si vous êtes rentré clandestinement
sur le territoire français ne vous
inquiétez pas il ya un jour où l'autre
où vous serez régularisés c'en est
terminé parce que ceci constitue un
appel d'air formidable pour
l'immigration clandestine pour ces
criminels que sont les passeurs qui peut
le faire leur sale commerce d'êtres
humains je veux y mettre un terme et à
partir de ce moment là il n'y aura plus
jamais de régularisation pour quelqu'un
qui est rentré clandestinement en france
et ça avant même l'été 2022
je le sais aussi on me dit que c'est pas
politiquement correct c'est pas
diplomatiquement correct oui mais je
suis prêt à engager un bras de fer avec
tout pays qui ne voudra pas reprendre
ses ressortissants qui doivent quitter
le territoire français jusqu'à
intraitable avec tout pays qui ne pourra
pas reprendre un délinquant qui aura
purgé sa peine de prison en france et
qui devra quitter le territoire aussitôt
après et il ne s'agit pas de faire de la
communication que monsieur macro et son
gouvernement en baissant le nombre de
visas non s'ils ne reprennent pas leurs
ressortissants
dans ces conditions là plus personne de
ce pays ne rentrera en france tant
qu'ils n'ont pas changé de politique de
leur président de la république jusqu'à
leurs étudiants en passant par les
dirigeants et par les entrepreneurs je
suis prêt à engager ce bras de fer pour
défendre les intérêts de la france et
des français quel que soit le pays dont
il s'agit
mes amis la droite républicaine elle
pose aussi un autre principe je ne
laisserai personne personne être jugée
sur sa couleur de peau son origine sa
religion ou son prénom mais je serai
intraitable intraitable avec celles et
ceux qui ne respectent pas les lois de
la république qui ne respectent pas nos
valeurs et ce quelle que soit leur
couleur de peau leur origine leur
religion ou leur prénom voilà ce que je
vous propose mes amis de la même façon
je le dis tous les musulmans ne sont pas
des islamistes tous les musulmans ne
sont pas des terroristes islamiques mais
les terroristes islamiques les
djihadistes qui nous ont déclaré la
guerre je mènerai ce combat contre tous
les jours quand il y a des mosquées
salafistes dans lesquels on pressent la
haine de la france et bien il ne s'agit
pas comme le fait monsieur macron d'en
fermer une de temps en temps ou un peu
plus souvent parce que les élections
approchent non les mosquées salafistes
et autres dans lesquels on prêche la
haine de la france fermés immédiatement
les prédicateurs de haine français
condamné les prédicateurs de haine
étrangers dehors voilà comment mais le
combat pour nous faire respecter parce
que je n'ai pas envie je n'ai pas envie
que mes enfants grandissent en baissant
la tête je n'ai pas envie que mes
enfants grandissent dans une france qui
serait différente de celle qui m'a vu
grandir par ses valeurs et vous l'avez
compris ce rétablissement de l'autorité
c'est un préalable est le préalable à
quoi à une société plus simple à une
société libérée et cette société libérée
ça veut dire qu'elle a mis un terme à ce
centralisme parisien qui nous étouffe il
ne s'agit pas des parisiens qui eux
d'ailleurs et aimerait bien être libéré
de l'emprise à la fois de la mairie de
paris avec madame hidalgo et de monsieur
macro mais c'est autre chose et le sait
qu'on peut compter sur l'engagement à la
fois d'agnès et de rachida non ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est que toute notre
vie se décide dans les palais
ministériel dans les administrations
centrales je vous propose la république
des territoires
la république des territoires pour que
l'on puisse clairement dire demain de
quelle façon nous voulons être gérée
gouverner notamment pour tout ce qui
concerne notre vie quotidienne à l'état
de s'occuper de la sécurité de la
justice de la lutte contre l'immigration
la lutte contre le terrorisme la
diplomatie la place de la france dans le
monde mais pour le reste bon sens pour
la santé pour la prise en charge du
handicap aurélien sur la question du
vieillissement sur ces questions
essentielles comme l'industrie
l'artisanat l'agriculture sur
l'éducation la formation cette
transition écologique que l'on demande
aussi aux élus de prendre davantage de
responsabilités
voilà ce que je propose dans cette
république des territoires et que nos
investissements soient aussi des
investissements qui profite à tout le
territoire les infrastructures que ce
soit la culture également et puis je
vous le dis en matière de logement on va
arrêter d'avoir une loi sru qui passe à
la toise toutes les communes de la même
façon sans faire la différence entre les
communes qui peuvent construire est
celle qui ne veulent pas construire et
puis aussi man who may ministre du
logement vous ne l'entendrez jamais vous
dire que le pavillon avec jardin c'est
has been et un nom modèles écologiques
si vous voulez continuer à vivre en
papillon si vous voulez que vos enfants
et vos petits enfants puissent le faire
vous continuerez à le faire en revanche
en revanche je demanderai je demanderai
à mon ministre du logement très
clairement de s'engager pour qu'enfin
dans la droite ligne de ce qu'a proposé
julien aubert à l'assemblée dominique
sassone estrosi au sénat le squatteur ne
soit plus considéré comme l'égal du
propriétaire et qu'on fasse respecter le
droit de propriété
l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est que nous ayons une
société plus juste plus juste et cette
société plus juste elle passera par le
travail elle sait faire la différence
entre la solidarité et l'assistanat et
elle redonnera aussi l'espoir de pouvoir
faire en sorte que ces enfants vivent
mieux que soi même déjà par le travail
oui
aucun mensonge toute la vérité c'est de
dire que nous ne nous en sortirons pas
si nous ne travaillons pas davantage et
pour cela le premier aspect nous allons
revenir au travailler plus pour gagner
plus en sortant en fin des 35 heures en
allongeant la durée du travail dans les
entreprises comme dans les entreprises
publiques
de la même façon participation et
intéressement plus de bénéficiaires et
plus de fonds pour la participation et
l'intéressement parce que ça montre
aussi une chose c'est que dans
l'entreprise quand l'entreprise réussit
c'est aussi grâce aux salariés et puis
surtout vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure
c'est d'autres idéal c'est notre idéal
depuis bien longtemps et ça relève de la
lutte des classes dans d'épais la cgt
bien loin derrière ou une entreprise
c'est l'endroit où on peut réussir et
faire réussir sa famille grâce à la
participation et à l'intéressement
et pour le reste que ce soit avec la
prime au travail que j'aurai l'occasion
d'expliquer certainement suite je veux
faire la différence je faire la
différence entre celui qui travaille et
celui qui pense qu'on peut s'en sortir
sans travail il est temps de mener une
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui fait
qu'on ne pourra pas rester le pays dans
lequel on peut continuer à dire non à
deux trois quatre cinq offres d'emploi
et qu'il ne se passe rien aujourd'hui
celui qui travaille celui qui ne
travaillent pas sont au même niveau que
ce soit avec les heures défiscaliser au
delà de la 35ème heures la participation
et l'intéressement et la prime au
travail pour ceux qui travaillent et le
fait de dire que celui qui ne veut pas
travailler celui là il aura une baisse
de ses allocations eh bien vous voyez
c'est avec une telle différence que vous
renouez avec une société française plus
juste et que vous renouez avec une
société française du travail voilà ce
que je vous propose mes amis c'est cet
espoir de plus de justice ils sont
essentiels pour nous mêmes alors
j'aurai encore beaucoup de choses à vous
dire mais le temps mais content et je
crois qu'à nice élevé à cause des mois
alors
je voudrais vous dire que l'énergie que
j'ai pour nous faire gagner c'est aussi
l'énergie que j'ai pour porter ce projet
et je sais pertinemment que vous même
vous avez une envie
la dernière fois que nous avons gagné
une élection présidentielle c'était en
2007 voilà une éternité une éternité
c'était avec nicolas sarkozy en 2012
n'avons pas gagné en 2017 nous avons été
éliminés du deuxième tour et nous savons
pertinemment que si c'est une troisième
fois un troisième échec et que nous
sommes éliminés du deuxième tour nous ne
réussirons pas nous relevé pourtant vous
savez bien que cette victoire est à
portée de la main alors c'est ce que je
vous propose avec tous les amis qui sont
ici c'est d'aller vers cette victoire de
déployer toute notre énergie d'expliquer
ce projet pour que le 24 avril ce ne
soit pas seulement notre victoire mais
celle de la france et des français voilà
l'enjeu
l'homme
même si chaque aviez alors pour lancer
pour lancer cette séquence de questions
je vais te poser une première question
depuis l'arrivée de manuel macron à
l'elysée on assiste en permanence
intègre un président tacticien qui
louvoie qui qui s'acoquinent tantôt avec
les uns tantôt avec les autres donnant
des gages ici ou là bref
un président qui n'a pas de ligne
directrice
mais dans laquelle certains ont la
faiblesse de penser qu'ils pourraient
représenter la droite
comment fait-on pour déjouer ce préjugé
selon lequel peut-être emmanuel macron
incarnerait certaines de nos positions
en particulier dans le domaine
économique tulle a reçu hier dans ta
région s'est présenté comme le sauveur
de l'industrie locale
toi tu sais bien que ce n'est pas le cas
mais à ceux qui ne sont pas des
professionnels de la politique comme
nous pouvons l'être qu'est ce que tu
dirais à quelqu'un qui pourrait penser
qu emmanuel macron incarnerait ce que
nous véritablement en vérité en loyauté
nous représentons vraiment c'est à dire
la droite et le centre
tu vas à nice que tu dis c'est souvent
ce que l'on entend de la part de
journalistes
de la part aussi d'observateurs
politiques ont dansé les mêmes dans mr
on est sérieux ou pas là macron de
droite on ne parlerait pas de la france
on ne parlerait pas d'élection
présidentielle il y aurait de quoi en
rire si monsieur macron était de droite
vous croyez qu'il serait capable d'aller
à la télévision comme il l'a fait au
lendemain du premier débat en disant en
matière de sécurité les résultats sont
là non mais personne ne les informe de
ce qui s'est passé à argenteuil la
semaine dernière avec les tirs de
mortiers sur les policiers personne ne
l'informent de ce qui s'est passé à
alençon encore et là on n'ait pas le
sentiment d'être au coeur d'une des
banlieues les plus difficiles nos villes
moyennes aussi sont concernés si macron
était de droite jamais il n'aurait
laissé autant de français pris en otage
du règne des bandes et des caïds dans
les quartiers voilà s'il était de droite
ce qu'il n'aurait pas fait s'il était de
droite il ne fermerait pas les mosquées
dans lesquels on prêche la haine une
fois de temps en temps s'il était de
droite il aurait repris vraiment le
contrôle de notre politique migratoire
et s'il était de droite il aurait fait
une politique pour tous les français
regardez l'enquète qui est sorti la
semaine dernière et s'il était de droite
il aurait aussi conscience qu'un pays
comme le nôtre effet d'entrepreneurs qui
réussit ce sont les entrepreneurs qui
créent de l'emploi palée politique ce
sont les entrepreneurs nous avons besoin
bien évidemment deux premiers de cordée
mail en france dans la france à laquelle
nous croyons chacun à sa place et chacun
doit pouvoir se faire une meilleure
place sur cette corde et il ya aussi
vous le savez bien parce que la droite
elle a du coeur
la droite elle est synonyme de justice
et lui je suis désolé il ne ressent pas
ce qu'est notre pays je l' ai vu hier
encore comme à chaque fois il a ses
certitudes plus que des convictions mais
comment peut-il ressentir les français
on est toujours le fruit de son parcours
annie et je suis intimement convaincu
qu'il ne ressent pas ces questions de
sécurité il ne ressent pas le sentiment
d'abandon de nombreux de nos concitoyens
et puis encore une fois la place du
travail comment peut-on accepter comment
peut-il tolérer que vous ayez des gens
qui travaillent qui travaillent dur mais
pour eux la fin du mois c'est pas le 30
du mois c'est le 5 du mois où c'est le
10 du mois quand tombent les
prélèvements s'il était de droite il
aurait aussi ce choeur là parce que
c'est nous qui l' continuons à nous
battre pour ceux qui travaillent il n'y
a que nous qui le faisons la gauche les
abandonner la gauche a abandonné cette
idée de changer la vie des gens
d'améliorer leur sort et donc tu le vois
bien aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas les
extrêmes ce n'est pas la gauche et ça
n'est pas monsieur macron je vous le dis
mes amis parce que parfois j'en ai un
peu marre qu'on nous dise mais au final
ce qu'il fait c'est c'est plutôt ce que
vous auriez fait mais jamais de la vie
entre 2002 et 2012 jacques chirac
président nicolas sarkozy ministre de
l'intérieur
2007 2012 nicolas sarkozy président de
la république et ensuite hollande et
makro ça n'a rien à voir rien à voir le
laxisme c'est eux l'autorité c'était
nous et tu me dis aussi en matière de
compétences à vous souvenez bien de ce
qu'avait dit monsieur macron à ses
ministres et à ses parlementaires soyez
fiers d'être des amateurs mais tous les
jours ils mettent sans pratiquer le
dernier exemple et notamment avec la
prime comme on l'appelle la
csc la prime élections là les 100 euros
la prime élections la prime à fleurs ou
et chaque élection chèque chaque
élection merci valérie chaque élection
regardez sur le côté amateurisme c'est
normalement pour la voiture pour
l'énergie une dame me disais dans le
jura mes amis sont là bas elle disait
mais j'ai une de mes amies elle est en
maison de retraite elle a plus de 80 ans
donc elle n'a pas de voiture elle touche
les 100 euros est par contre
l'infirmière qui vient à domicile elle
gagne plus de 2000 euros donc elle a
droit à rien je vous le dis mes amis des
amateurs ce chèque était impossible au
moment de la crise et gilet jaune il
devient possible à cinq mois des
élections s'il était de droite il ne
ferait pas campagne chaque semaine avec
le chéquier de la france cette attitude
est indigne et je le dis il étant
clairement de montrer que sa politique
n'est pas de droite et encore une fois
et encore une fois il y a bien quelque
chose qui lui est étranger c'est la
notion d'esprit de justice parce que la
justice a clairement c'est une valeur de
droite annie
vous aviez en 1995 j'étais bébé jacques
chirac que mène une magnifique campagne
présidentielle il a un discours très
ferme sur les questions régaliennes
parce que nous sommes les républicains
que nous sommes garants de cet ordre là
mais ils gagnent sur la fracture sociale
sur l'espoir de donner une espérance à
chaque français en 2007 nicolas sarkozy
vous le savez j'étais un peu plus grand
je m'en souviens mène campagne très
ferme sur les questions régaliennes mais
ils gagnent sur le travailler plus pour
gagner plus comment demain serons nous
capable au-delà du rétablissement si
nécessaire de l'ordre de porter un
espoir quatre ans après être rentré dans
la vie professionnelle
un fils de cadres gagne 1200 euros de
plus qu un fils d'ouvrier comment
pouvons-nous demain rétablir cette
promesse républicaine celle de
l'ascenseur social un pays un grand pays
un beau pays comme la france qui n'est
pas capable de promettre à un gamin de
clichy sous bois un gamin du 7e
arrondissement de paris où un gamin du
lot la même réussite si le produit les
mêmes efforts n'est pas un pays qui
s'appelle la france tu veux rétablir la
grandeur de la france ça commence
sûrement pas l'ascenseur social
comment s'y prend-on
avec l agent 95
je vais te dire pourquoi ce combat pour
la justice est un combat si important
pour moi c'est important parce qu'on est
toujours le fruit de son parcours
il s'avère que mes parents sont nés en
1947 ce sont des baby boomers
et quand ils m'ont eu ma maman avait 18
ans et une semaine mon père 18 ans et
deux mois la majorité à 21 ans vous
imagine assez facilement que mon arrivée
n'était pas prévu de si longue date mais
du coup mon père a dû changer un peu ses
projets il voulait faire des études
supérieures
hélas pas pu parce que l'indépendance
l'amener à prendre le premier boulot qui
venait il a commencé à être commandité
pions dans un collège je crois est
ensuite très vite nous sommes arrivés à
3 parce qu'il y avait des postes qui
étaient ouverts dans la banque à
l'époque dans la banque on pouvait
grimper les échelons on pouvait grimper
les échelons il a passé des examens des
examens professionnels
il a pas réussi du premier coup il
travaillait à la maison ça me surprenait
un peu que les parents travaillent à la
maison et il a réussi et il a eu des
promotions quant à eu des promotions
l'appartement est devenu plus grands
n'est pas devenu riche on a quitté le h
m dans lequel on était à 3 dans lesquels
on est très heureux la voiture est
devenue un peu plus grande les vacances
se faisait en allant un peu plus loin
mais c'est tout simplement parce qu'il a
travaillé qu'on avait cette possibilité
à l'époque tu vois aurélien il fallait
une génération pour pouvoir le faire
aujourd'hui il faut six générations
quand on rentre troisième étage de la
société française pour passer au
quatrième étage et j'ai nombre
d'exemples je le vois chaque fin de
réunion les gens viennent me voir en
disant l'histoire de votre père c'est la
nôtre mes oncles et tantes n'ont pas
fait d'études supérieures mais ils ont
eu des bonnes places dans des bonnes
entreprises sans être cadres dirigeants
parce qu'à l'époque il y avait les cours
du soir si nous ne mettons pas un terme
à ces plafonds de verre qui l'y a
partout dans la société française y'aura
pas d'espoir et nous aurons au final
quoi à nouveau déat jalousie des
jalousies sociale on va se regarder en
chiens de faïence on va se retrouver un
jour face à face comme les images le
montraient tout à l'heure non et je
pense que la véritable vocation le
véritable projet que doit mener la
droite république cette droite populaire
parce que populaire ça veut dire tout le
monde ceux qui n'ont pas de problèmes de
fin de mois ceux qui ont des fins de
mois difficiles mais les classes
moyennes oui je la dirige l'assument je
pense qu'il est temps de faire un effort
plus important encore pour les classes
moyennes et ne vous demandez pas au
final quel est le barème quel est le
revenu des classes moyennes vous
inquiétez pas c'est très facile à savoir
classes moyennes trop riche pour être
aidé que ce soit pour les bourses pour
l'apa pour faire face aux dépenses liées
au vieillissement mais toujours trop
riche pour être aidés parce que si vous
dépassez de quelques zéros vous n'avez
droit à rien voilà ce que sur les
classes moyennes et les temps de leur
montrer que c'est nous qui les
symbolisons et c'est nous qui pouvons
leur redonner de l'espoir c'est ça le
véritable enjeu et cela se fait à la
fois par le travail c'est vrai je les
dis la prime au travail qui permettra
que ya plus une personne à temps complet
qui est moins de 1500 euros net par mois
c'est la participation l'intéressement
c'est les heures mais il ya aussi autre
chose aurélien c'est qu'il y à celles et
ceux qui ne peuvent pas travailler ou
qui ne peuvent plus travailler je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure que c'est la
droite qui aujourd'hui symbolise l'idéal
de justice c'est la droite qui a sucker
parce que les retraités ces retraités
nos aînés dans le collimateur de
monsieur macron depuis le début de ce
quinquennat ces retraités à qui il y a
eu l'augmentation de la csg est
aujourd'hui les retraites
complémentaires qui augmentent moins que
l'inflation parce que monsieur macro n'a
pas eu le courage de mener la réforme
des retraites et puis parfois on ne peut
pas travailler à cause du handicap sujet
que tu connais bien que tu portes au
sein de notre famille politique parce
que ça c'est une question de justice
j'estime pour ma part si on ne veut pas
confondre le travail le travail et le
ceux qui font le choix du non travail si
on ne pas confondre la solidarité et
l'assistanat il faut être très fermes
pour mettre un terme aux dérives de
l'assistanat mais il faut aussi savoir
être plus solidaires avec ceux qui en
ont besoin est ce que vous pensez
vraiment que la france est si généreuse
que cela quand un adulte handicapé
recevra 908 euros par mois même quand
ses parents seront partis est-ce que
vous pensez que la france est si
généreuse que ça quand il ya le minimum
vieillesse keita 903 euros par mois et
encore parce que de 2007 à 2012 même
avec la crise financière nicolas sarkozy
a exigé qu'il y ait là revalorise sion
de ces deux allocations de 20% 25% sur
tout le quinquennat tu t'en souviens
nadine alors qu'il aurait été facile en
pleine crise de dire non on n'augmente
pas parce que c'est cet idéal de justice
et je suis intimement convaincu que ce
soit sur ses fragilités il ya des mamans
ou dans la vie on peut s'en sortir on
doit s'en sortir par le travail mais à
l'aube de la vie la petite enfance au
soir de la vie le vieillissement la
dépendance et aussi quand il y à des
accidents de la vie et bien je vous le
dis c'est à ces moments là que l'état
doit être là et dans le projet que je
porte avec vous devant vous j'ai la
conviction que la droite républicaine
est celle qui doit marquer que la
justice s'est clairement dans son adn
merci de cette question sincèrement
merci et xavier lot il ya pas mal de
gens qui veulent te poser les questions
il nous reste 23 minutes donc des
questions brèves et des réponses qu'ils
ne le seront pas moins on commence par
le microbe le
bonjour monsieur bertrand
je m'appelle edouard varin j'ai 20 ans
je suis élu conseiller national dans la
fédération de l'heure où je suis
également élu conseiller municipal
d'opposition à gaillon je suis jeune et
comme beaucoup de jeunes je me pose des
questions par rapport à l'avenir par
rapport à l'écologie et parmi les
questions écologiques il ya les
questions énergétiques et je me pose
donc aujourd'hui la question je vous
pose la question quelles seraient vos
priorités quel serait votre vision au
niveau de la transition énergétique
au cours de votre mandat je vous
remercie
je dois faire des réponses courtes
d'accord donc je peux pas parler premier
emploi orientation je peux pas parler
premier logement je peux pas parler
mobilité je dois parler que transition
énergétique alors je vais parler que
transition énergétique je parlais
transition énergétique et l indique très
clairement je ne veux pas sortir du
nucléaire je ne veux pas abaisser la
part du nucléaire avec moi il n'y aura
pas de décroissance de la part du
nucléaire dans notre pays
attendez attendez
je veux vous expliquer pourquoi et
comment
pourquoi parce qu'on a quand même en
france une capacité chez certains
dirigeants à casser ce qui marche
autrement dit à se tirer une balle dans
le pied le nucléaire c'est la
souveraineté c'est l'indépendance de la
france ça nous a été légué par le
général de gaulle et ben non on voudrait
à baisser la part du nucléaire la part
du nucléaire c'est l'indépendance
énergétique
le nucléaire c'est aussi ce qui fait que
la facture d'électricité
elle est moins cher qu'en allemagne et
ben non il faudrait bien évidemment
diminuer la part du nucléaire et je vous
le dis mes amis gouverner c'est prévoir
gouverner c'est anticiper regardons ce
qui se passe devant nous
la souveraineté l'indépendance
j'ai envie qu'on sorte de la guerre
froide avec la russie j'ai pas envie de
dépendre de monsieur poutine pour
l'approvisionnement en gaz dans les
années qui viennent mais on va aller
plus loin on va avoir des voitures de
plus en plus électrique enfin si je peux
me permettre pas trop vite parce que
j'ai pas envie qu'il ya une casse
sociale monumental dans un secteur clef
qui est en france l'industrie automobile
a bonne entendeur j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir sur les échéances qui nous sont
proposés imposée par la commission
européenne je ne ferai pas la transition
énergétique au détriment des classes
moyennes ni au détriment de l'emploi a
bonne entendeur a bonne entendeur
mais sur la question du nucléaire je
pense qu'il nous faut lancer très
rapidement dix nouveaux réacteurs et et
entendons nous bien les uns et des
autres nous voulons ne pas diminuer la
part du nucléaire très bien mais dans
ces cas là il faut l'augmenter parce que
vous ne pourrez pas mener de front à la
fois
l'électrification tout le marché
automobile et la réindustrialisation
nous ne reviendrons pas le grand pays
que nous avons été en matière
industrielle si nous ne mettons pas le
paquet sur l'industrie et comment on va
les alimenter nos nouvelles usines même
si c'est avec de l'hydrogène de
l'hydrogène vers ça passera aussi par le
nucléaire et comprenez moi bien jamais
je ne remplacerai nos centrales
nucléaires par les satanés zeo lienne et
nous coûtent les yeux de la tête et qui
sont en train de défigurer la des plus
beaux pays au monde qu'est la france
donc sur tous ces sujets et ne vous fiez
pas tiani mais au final est ce que
monsieur macro mènerait pas une
politique de droite parce qu'ils
relancent le nucléaire et soyons sérieux
soyons sérieux il nous a fait cette
belle déclaration parce qu'il s'est
aperçu au lendemain du premier débat des
républicains d'ailleurs on sait ce qui
fait un contient débat des républicains
il regarde la télé monsieur ils
regardent la télé c'est pas des bonne
soirée pour lui mais regarde la télé et
donc le lendemain il va la télévision
pour dire oh là il faut construire des
réacteurs non mais soyons sérieux c'est
le même qui nous disaient voilà trois
ans le 27 novembre 2018 j'ai pas dis
voilà trente ans j'ai dit voilà trois
ans c'est le même qui nous disait il
faut fermer des réacteurs nucléaires et
c'est celui qui à fermer fessenheim qui
vient nous dire aujourd'hui le contraire
franchement les français ne faut pas les
prendre pour des imbéciles
si vous voulez faire le choix de
l'indépendance énergétique de la
transition et du nucléaire c'est pour
nous qu'il pauvreté d'or monsieur macron
le micro jaune s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je suis andré reynaud je suis
rdj du vaucluse je travaille dans le
secteur de l'agroalimentaire et j'ai une
question sur la place de la france dans
le monde quand on voit aujourd'hui la
chine qui rachète absolument toutes les
réserves de métal quand on voit le
fiasco des sous marins australiens quand
on voit un président de la république
qui souhaite laisser notre siège au
conseil sécurité de l'onu à une nation
européenne plutôt qu'à la france moi je
me pose une question quelle place pour
la france dans le monde de demain
[Applaudissements]
c'est audrey votre prénom audrey la
place de la france dans le monde c'est
pas celle d'un petit pays c'est pas
celle d'un pays en deuxième division il
n'y aura qu'un général de gaulle dans
l'histoire de france un seul un seul
mais il y a une pensée gaulliste qui
nous inspire et qui nous obligent qui
nous oblige aussi à tenir notre place et
pas celle de n'importe quel pays pour
certains notre puissance et la culture
la francophonie pour d'autres notre
puissance et la force de dissuasion
nucléaire qui nous protège nous et qui
nous protège aussi sur tout le continent
européen
mais c'est aussi l'outre-mer j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure et vous n'êtes pas
vous choqué par le silence assourdissant
de monsieur macro quant à l'avenir de la
nouvelle calédonie je le dis à tous nos
amis je le dis à pierre frogier l
ensemble des élus calédoniens nous nous
disons clairement ce que nous voulons
la nouvelle calédonie je n'ai pas envie
qu'elle soit chinoise un jour alors je
souhaite qu'elle reste française parce
que c'est notre influence et notre
présence dans le pacifique dont il est
question aussi en la matière
et puis il ya la question du siège au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu est bien là
aussi si vous me faites confiance si les
français me font confiance jamais je ne
partagerais le siège au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu ni avec l'allemagne ni
avec l'union européenne
que les choses soient claires mais ce
qui veut dire aussi qu'il faut se faire
respecter en tout point et sur tous les
dossiers prenez les américains ce sont
nos amis ce sont nos alliés on ne va pas
rentrer en guerre avec les américains
c'est une évidence
mais on ne peut pas avoir été humilié
comme nous l'avons été dans la sphère
des sous marins australiens et se
contenter de quoi d'une bonne poignée de
mains devant les caméras de télévision
avec monsieur byden et puis d'une
caresse dans le dos non mais franchement
vous pensez qu'on peut accepter cela il
ya une chose qui était exigée c'est une
réunion du conseil de l'otan une réunion
extraordinaire pour que l'on dise
clairement ou valent autant bien
évidemment nous y sommes revenus avec
nicolas sarkozy dans le commandement
intégré mais si le temps est une machine
à faire la guerre froide avec la chine
et demain faire la guerre je pense qu'il
faut une explication président de la
république je n'hésiterai pas un instant
à changer la nature de nos relations
avec la chine mais si c'est l'intérêt de
la france et pas parce que les
américains lors on décider à notre place
voilà ma conception de l'indépendance
et on ne se laisse pas insulter par
monsieur erdogan comme il l'a fait
vis-à-vis du président macron c'est
pourquoi elle ma réponse a toujours été
la même et ma position a toujours été
constante la turquie n'a pas sa place
dans l'union européenne et je les dis
aussi dans cette campagne comme nicolas
sarkozy à l'époque et l'algérie
l'algérie est un pays avec lequel notre
histoire c'est vrai a été difficile mais
nous avons cette relation d'amitié mais
s'être lille sera une relation d'amitié
elle ne peut pas être terni par les
insultes d'un ministre algérien au sénat
algérien vis-à-vis de la france et nous
ne pouvons pas accepter peux pas
accepter qu'on nous interdise de
survoler l'espace aérien algérien en
rétorsion rétorsion de quoi alors que
nous avons besoin que nos avions
survolent leur espace aérien pour aller
aux maillys au sahel pour combattre le
terrorisme si l'algérie maintient cette
position je n'hésiterai pas à revenir
sur les accords bilatéraux de 1968 entre
la france et l'algérie mais il est vrai
que l'algérie se sert d'une chose de
cette phrase
impardonnable prononcé par monsieur
macron à la dernière élection
présidentielle où il avait osé parler de
crimes contre l'humanité de la part de
la france jamais je ne lui pardonnerai
cette phrase prononcée en algérie et je
tiens aussi à vous le dire
ça veut dire aussi être sur lui tous les
dossiers en anticipant regarder ce qui
est en train de se passer aujourd'hui en
iran les iraniens recommence à faire
fonctionner leur centrifugeuses et que
fait-on où est la france aux abonnés
absents un grand pays doit toujours
aussi être en anticipation et ne pas
hésiter c'est vrai à jouer le jeu des
alliances si ça permet de préserver son
indépendance c'est ça qui nous a
enseigné clairement le général de gaulle
et j'ai bien conscience que vous savez
une élection présidentielle
c'est pas une élection régionale en
grand non il faut avoir conscience qu'on
doit être le président des français de
tous les français aurélien mais qu'on
est aussi dépositaire des intérêts de
notre pays un grand pays qui n'en n'a
pas fini d'étonner le monde si on en a
la volonté et je tiens aussi à dire que
si vous me faites confiance si les
français me font confiance j'aurais
écrire pendant cinq années les belles
pages de ce grand livre de l'histoire de
la france et des français mais qu'on se
le tienne pour dit si certaines pages de
l'histoire par le passé ne vous plaisent
pas ne comptez pas sur moi pour les
réécrire ou pour les déchirer je ne
serai pas un président de la repentance
ne comptez pas sur moi pour déboulonner
des statuts l'histoire de mon pays est
un bloc je suis fier de mon pays alors
je suis fière de son histoire et de la
place qui tient dans le monde et il doit
continuer à tenir dans le monde
même si
on passait au micro et orange au fond
monsieur oui
monsieur le président bertrand je
m'appelle syrie gank aimant j'ai 33 ans
je suis élue municipale etc territoriale
de cette belle ville d'issy les
moulineaux je suis également
universitaire ma question est simple
comment assurez-vous la pérennité des
retraites quelle réforme ferait vous
lorsque vous serez élu président car
nous avons tous confiance en vous quelle
réforme prendrait vous pour sauver nos
retraites je vous remercie
en conduisant cette réforme mais avec
deux maîtres mots le courage et la
justice courage et justice c'est l'adn
de la droite républicaine
j'ai l'expérience de trois réforme des
retraites que nous avons conduite et la
réforme des retraites celle que j'ai en
tête pour commencer c'est celle de 2003
françois fillon à la demande de jacques
chirac cette réforme des retraites elle
été difficile on l'oubli on oublie bien
souvent les choses on oublie les choses
parce que à l'époque même durée de
cotisation publiques et privées du monde
dans la rue des millions de personnes
dans la rue nous avons tenu courage mais
nous avons fait preuve de justice vous
souvenez de ce qu'il y avait dans cette
réforme il y avait les carrières longues
les carrières longues le fait que quand
on avait commencé à travailler à 14 ans
à 15 ans et à 16 ans on pouvait partir
avant 60 ans s'était demandé depuis des
années et je me souviens quand il a
fallu discuter avec
les gens des ministères qui nous et ça
va coûter cher parce que s'ils partent
plutôt qu'ils cotiseront plus fort à
leur verser une pension et bien moi je
me suis souvenu d'une chose c'est qu'en
2002 quand j'étais candidat aux
législatives je vais dans une
exploitation agricole
fermiers qui est l'âme fait un café avec
ses salariés il y en a un qui me dit bon
si vous êtes élue la chirac a dit qu'ils
voulaient faire la réforme des retraites
dites vous bien une chose et l'oublié
pas j'ai commencé à travailler à 15 ans
j'adore mon métier mais j'en ai 57 passé
est clairement celle de broyer je
pourrai pas aller au bout alors c'est
vrai quand on nous a dit que ça coûtait
cher je me suis aussi souvenu de ce que
m'a dit ce monsieur parce que la
politique ses pattes des chiffres la
politique c'est de l'humain et on le
voit bien aussi si vous aimez pas les
gens fait pas de politique si vous
comprenez pas si vous entendez pas si
vous aimez pas les français ne vous
présentez pas l'élection présidentielle
parce que c'est ça qu'il ne faut jamais
oublier bien sûr qu'il faut savoir
compter comme valérie comme laurent
comme d'autres présidents de région à la
tête de ma région non seulement j'ai pas
augmenter les impôts gb c'est celui qui
est le seul qu'on avait mais j'ai aussi
en tête en permanence on dépense pas
plus que ce qu'on a bien sûr que je sais
qu'il faudra mener la réforme des
retraites bien sûr que je sais qu'il
faudra mener la réforme de l'assurance
chômage voulaient dit tout à l'heure la
baisse de la dépense publique éviter les
doublons lutter contre les fraudes
mettre un terme à leymen non seulement
elle coûte mais aussi on sait bien
qu'elle a un effet aspirants pour les
filières d'immigration clandestine tout
ça je suis décidé à le faire mais je
sais aussi que ses efforts de réduction
des dépenses devront servir à nous
désendetter garder encore une fois la
maîtrise l'indépendance comme le disait
audrey sur un autre domaine
l'indépendance c'est de réduire la dette
c'est de réduire les impôts je veux
commencer par les impôts de production
mais je sais aussi pour toutes les
classes moyennes qui l'y a aussi une
attente qui est une attente sur l'impôt
sur le revenu j'en ai conscience et puis
il y aura aussi cet investissement
nécessaire dans les services publics oui
mieux comme s'était dit tout à l'heure
dans une pétition mais ça veut dire
aussi on peut pas laisser la santé au
bord de l'effondrement
que ce soit à l'hôpital philippe mais
que ce soit également dans le système
libéral dans notre système de santé tel
qu'il est on ne peut pas continuer à
voir aussi peu de magistrats si on veut
que la loi pénale soit appliqué plus
sévèrement on voit bien aujourd'hui que
nous avons besoin nous désendetter de
baisser les impôts c'est dans l'adn de
la droite républicaine mais aussi dans
un certain nombre de services publics
avec moins d'agents j'en suis convaincu
mais en recherchant en permanence
l'efficacité
donc cette réforme on va l'amener et je
veux dès l'été 2022 co langage cette
grande réforme des retraites après les
concertations à la fin de cette décennie
il faudra avoir deux ans de plus
cotisations durée du travail
et puis ensuite il faudra aller plus
loin encore certains disent également je
le dis aussi ce sera 65 ans en fonction
de l'espérance de vie mais attention
ceux qui sont usés physiquement par leur
travail devront faire un chemin qui sera
plus court que 64 ou 65 ans et tant et
tant que la carrière et que les salaires
des femmes ne sont pas les mêmes que
pour les hommes où il est normal de
garder les avantages familiaux non
seulement pour les femmes mais au nom de
la conception que je me fais de la
famille dans notre pays voilà des
exemples concrets et je ne joue pas sur
les mots on ne pourra pas continuer au
nom de la justice avoir des gens qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie et penser
encore aux femmes qui ont des retraites
de misère ça voudra dire augmenter le
niveau minimum des pensions y compris
des pensionnés d'aujourd'hui y compris
des retraités d'aujourd'hui voilà ce que
je vous propose courage et jeu this
c'est clairement l'adn qui est le nôtre
merci et xavier dont on passe au micro
orange
bonjour monsieur bertrand bastien
corsini conseiller national de
lot-et-garonne vous êtes un des rares
candidats a osé parler des territoires
je viens d'un département où il y sommes
projet structurant pour le territoire
qui divise particulièrement étant donné
qu'il s'agit du gps au à savoir plus
connu sous le nom de lgv
bordeaux toulouse et bordeaux pays
basque
les élus du département de tous bords
ont refusé de financer leur part de pour
ce projet résultat le gouvernement est
appuyée par le parlement ont voté très
récemment une nouvel impôt sur pour
financer cette lgv alors ma question est
très simple après le scandale de notre
dame des landes après les gilets jaunes
dénonçant la verticalité du projet du
pouvoir à quand la reconnaissance et
l'application réelle des référendums
locaux notamment sur les projets
structurants pour les territoires
où ça peut aussi se sont aussi s'agir de
fusion ou scissions de communautés de
communes ou de communes nouvelles
mais enfin quand est ce que les citoyens
auront leur mot à dire dans votre
république des territoires
ils auront leur mot à dire de deux
façons la première c'est que ce que je
propose c'est qu'on transfère
massivement des compétences des libertés
des responsabilités aux élus locaux
plutôt plutôt
qu'aux responsables dans les ministères
les directeurs d'administration centrale
parce que les élus locaux vous les
connaissez ah j'ai oublié de vous dire
mère un jour maire toujours certainement
dans ma tête j'étais mère et je sais
pertinemment que le maire à cette
relation si particulière avec nos
concitoyens le premier recours quand il
y a un projet et parfois le dernier
recours quand il y a un problème alors
moi je leur fais confiance je ne suis
pas content de les trouver seulement au
lendemain de la crise et gilet jaune
comme l'a fait monsieur macro avec ce
grand débat tiens vous avez entendu
parler vous des conclusions du grand
débat vous savez où elles sont passées
vous savez où elles ont été utilisées
jamais c'est un gâchis nationale qui
montre bien que pour lui ce n'était pas
un exercice de respiration démocratique
n'était pas le fait d'écouter les
français c'était un artifice de
communication donc déjà les élus ou où
est il passé pardon je cherchais c'est
déjà cédé et lui et je le dis également
je ne serai pas un président qui pensera
qu'il ya trop de communes dans notre
pays
les regroupements forcés de communes
avec moi ce sera clairement non il n'en
est pas question je sais pertinemment
que l'intercommunalité est là parce que
l'union fait la force mais il ya
beaucoup de communes qui nous disent
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on coûte
pourquoi on est aujourd'hui complètement
déposséder d'urbanisme et du logement
donc moi il n'est pas question que
j'aille vers ce mouvement de
concentration de disparition des
communes le maire la commune rurale
c'est bien souvent le meilleur rapport
qualité prix de la république et si vous
les supprimez vous voulez faire croire
créer les postes de fonctionnaires en
plus certainement pas certainement pas
parce qu'il ya aussi cette dimension
humaine et territoriales en revanche et
là je ne vais pas faire un tabac avec
tout le monde on me dit qu'il faut que
j'évite certains sujets candidats un
congrès candidat à la présidentielle
faut pas se faire d'ennemis je suis par
contre pour que l'on mette en place le
conseiller territorial
je pense que le tandem région
département on peut le simplifier
que notre millefeuille politico
administratif français il est beaucoup
trop compliqué quatre mille conseillers
départementaux aujourd'hui 2000
conseillers régionaux je propose que
nous ayons 4000 élus territoriaux
le même élu au département et à la
région vous avez un sujet sur le rsa
vous avez besoin de renseignements ou
d'une aide sur l'insertion mon dieu si
vous avez besoin d'une formation
qualifiante vous n'avez plus qu'à prier
pour que le département et la région
s'entendent bien vous avez une cité
scolaire à rénover le collège et lycée
quand est-ce qu'on fait le calendrier
des travaux tout ça c'est quasiment
difficile ou impossible avec le
conseiller territorial ce sera possible
ça veut dire moins de doublons ça veut
dire plus efficacité et comment par la
proximité et donc il y à la question des
élus et je crois aussi aux référendums
locaux je le dis les référendums locaux
ont du sens mais à une condition c'est
qu'on tienne compte du résultat est
qu'on ne bafoue pas la place du résultat
c'est bruno retailleau qui m'avait
expliqué comment avait été ressentie
dans les pays de loire cette injustice
qu on ait demandé l'avis des habitants
sur notre dame des landes et qu'on se
soit assis dessus si vous demandez
l'avis des gens alors il faut en tenir
compte et c'est l'un des points sur
lequel je veux insister
j'ai toujours indiqué je leur dis devant
vous je suis candidat pour un mandat de
cinq ans je suis candidat pour un mandat
de cinq ans seulement
vous l'avez compris ceux qui me
connaissent depuis longtemps le savent
je ne manque pas d'énergie mais je pense
qu'il faut consacrer toute son énergie à
remettre notre pays sur ses pieds à
réconcilier et à rassembler les français
comme beaucoup d'entre vous j'ai voté à
l'époque pour le passage au quinquennat
j'ai pensé que c'était une bonne chose
de voter plus souvent sauf qu'on est
rentré dans un système à l'américaine où
dès qu'on est élu on pense à faire un
deuxième mandat je veux me consacrer
uniquement au redressement de notre pays
au rassemblement des français et à
redonner de l'espoir je sais je vois
certains mouvements que vous n'êtes pas
forcément en phase à 100% je vous livre
ma conviction parce que vous devez
savoir ce que j'ai dans le coeur dans le
ventre et dans la tête c'est ça aussi la
vérité et la transparence et je le dis
un président qui ne se représentera pas
sait pertinemment qu'il n'a pas à avoir
peur du peuple il y à des sujets sur
lesquels bien évidemment les
parlementaires décideront mais sur des
sujets essentiels qui touche notamment
aux changements constitutionnels je veux
que ce soit les français qui se prononce
qu'il nous dise comment ils veulent être
protégé en matière de sécurité de
justice de lutte contre le terrorisme
comment ils veulent reprendre en main la
politique migratoire et comment ils ne
veulent que plus jamais ce soit l'europe
qui nous indique qu'elle doit être le
temps de travail de nos militaires ou de
nos pompiers c'est ça aussi la
souveraineté je veux que ce soit les
français qu'ils disaient y a pas plus
courageux que le peuple français alors
moi je n'en ai pas peur c'est la raison
pour laquelle je m'engage avec toute mon
énergie pour un mandat justement pour
faire et pour remettre notre pays
clairement sur la bonne trajectoire et
dans la bonne direction est ce que je
veux au niveau national je le veux
également au niveau local je crois à la
démocratie
je crois au peuple et moi j'ai pas peur
du peuple
merci
merci xavier on va s'en tenir là parce
qu'on arrive oui un mot de conclusion
peut-être
un mot de conclusion pour dire au delà
de cet échange qui est ressemble à tous
les échanges que j'ai eus dans toutes
ses réunions et je continuerai
passionnément jusqu'au premier entre le
2 et le 3 et puis ensuite si vous me
faites confiance pour aller chercher
cette victoire à l'élection
présidentielle
vous l'avez compris ce qui est important
pour nos concitoyens c'est notre mode de
vie je voulais dit j'ai envie que mes
enfants 25 ans 15 ans 15 ans 3 ans et
demi grandi dans une france qui
ressemble furieusement à la mienne qui
ressemble par ses valeurs à la mienne
mais j'ai aussi envie que l'on n'est
plus aujourd'hui tant de français qui
travaillent qui sont attachés au travail
qui n'y arrivent plus parce que c'est la
marque d'un pays qui va dans le mur
chacun est le fruit de son parcours de
son histoire personnelle de son parcours
professionnel de son parcours politique
j'aime mon pays passionnément et je suis
comme vous ce que j'ai de plus cher
c'est mon pays et mes enfants
c'est le sens de ce projet c'est pas un
projet comme le disent certains qui ne
vise à parler que des questions de
sécurité d'autorité c'est le préalable à
tout mais nous voulons avoir une france
qui soit libéré de son carcan
administratif qui laisse respirer les
français et nous voulons surtout une
france plus juste dans laquelle on se
dit que là où on habite
quelle que soit la situation familiale
quelles que soient ses études on a la
possibilité de vivre mieux et de faire
vivre au mieux ses enfants nous ne
sommes pas n'importe quel pays on a une
histoire formidable on encore une
histoire formidable devant nous c'est ce
à quoi je vous invite mes amis je vous
le dis franchement si je gagne ce
congrès j'en prends l'engagement je
gagnerai cette élection présidentielle
parce que nous savons bien qu'il va
falloir aller la chercher cette présence
au second tour il faudra aller chercher
cette victoire mais il est temps
aujourd'hui que notre famille politique
montre la voie et qu'elle redonne de
l'espoir pour la france et pour les
français vive la république vive la
france
[Applaudissements]